[Music]
when I tell people that I'm a wrestler
they don't really believe me at first I
don't know what image they have in their
head of what a wrestler should look like
especially when I say I'm the super
heavyweight for women's wrestling and
they're like you wrestle like you're
you're kind of too pretty to wrestle and
so it's always interesting to make them
like what did you expect
[Music]
my name is adilyn gray I'm a three-time
world champion ranked number one in the
world been undefeated for two and a half
years and I'm going to compete in the
Rio Olympic Games in August I never
really considered the Olympics as an
option for me when I was younger kid and
it's something that I don't think enough
girls have an opportunity to dream about
I want to redefine feminine to some
extent and and to have people challenge
the way they look at the word strong and
not just see a boy that pops into your
head
I started wrestling boys I was six years
old and I wrestled boys all the way
through high school and I think I earned
a lot of respect from a lot of the the
teammates out there who did lose to me
or maybe beat me and I got to train with
the best guys in the world and they made
me tougher they made me work for every
single point I had to wrestle with and
and they made it so that I could be a
champion on the women's level now we
teach girls to be perfect and boys to
take risks I need to take risks that I
am a confident strong female who knows
that I'm great at wrestling I'm still
struggling with that concept that I'm
worried about not being perfect when I
step on the mat
I have to step on that mat and make sure
that I work every single moment to win
an Olympic gold medal I want young girls
to be able to look at thatmy situation
and be able to dream about it I'm
excited for that moment to have my five
risen and and be able to know that I'm
gonna hold a gold medal around my neck
[Music]
I feel like there's like a glass ceiling
for women because I've hit it if you
skate and you rip then you should just
get what you deserve if like
skateboarding is supposed to be for
everybody if we do actually want any
form of equality or space like we're
gonna have to be the ones to create that
space my name is Lacey Baker and I'm a
professional skateboarder I discovered
skateboarding when I was really really
young like two years old I was in foster
care at that time and I would watch my
foster brother escape a mini-ramp and I
just was like immediately obsessed like
I was like I have to do this I started
competing when I was 11 years old when I
was 22 I skated the 2014 X Games in
Austin and that's the year I won the
gold with women and skateboarding
there's like a subculture within a
subculture the ski industry like just
doesn't care about women's skating it's
not equal for example like there is a
skateboard contest series which didn't
use to include women in it but it just
started to however is the prize for
first place is 30 grand and like for the
guys first place is 200 grand I feel
like it should be because we work just
as hard as the guys
Meo skateboards is a company that was
created to like support women in
skateboarding I do my own board graphics
like I do a lot of the other girls board
graphics and like it's rad cuz it's like
skater own and it's like for us and it's
like bhaiyya
so it's like there's nothing corporate
about it and it feels like like that's
how it's supposed to be even if nothing
comes of like like having asked a career
or like anything like that like I still
have skating and like I believe in being
yourself and like you know just doing
whatever the [ __ ] you want that's what
skating is supposed to be
I think everybody thinks that 2012 was a
fluke like I got lucky or something I'm
the first black white whatever the first
woman to an Olympic gold medal in boxing
and I did it when I was 17 I thought I
would have endorsements and sponsorships
but you know that didn't happening I am
the best in the box on where I grew up
in Flint Michigan like you know when you
talk you seem like a bully are you
seeing pretty no if you want us to do
your hair will do your hair and I was I
was home so I can't express how great
they want the pretty girl back to
everything I sailed nothing is wrong
with my personality maybe this is the
peak of my career maybe 17 with it maybe
one Olympic gold medal and I start
having kids now moving breathing
dinosaurs in their natural environment
see the amazing 2040 rates
[Music]
[Music]
people in Flint are so used to just
somebody being successful and then
falling off Flint has limits nobody
wants to get in the sky and see what's
beyond the clouds type thing I think for
some people do they get stuck here and
they don't get out the bsp tend to kind
of get used to it
and they see no other way of life
[Music]
he loves your mind
I cover mama ain't of the bargain with
you I just went to your school shopping
and got your two pair of shoes but I can
tell you go to school play football
ma you don't know [ __ ] is that what
happened to be here thank you went to
the term Brazilian way September's no
you're fooling us 11 27 bro for not let
you decide your own life by your
education for her so you think you know
I think all the school's done in my fuel
a turbo because you will make mad and I
want to make me mad and what you get o
about I know that my family wants to see
me do well but they don't know that some
of the things that they do can't hurt me
duel you know we always had a deal even
when I was younger
once you're stepping through the gym
outside problems stay out the gym you
know like I have everything to lose
because I do
I fight the longer I'm here the further
I drift away
you know drift back into being here I
really you know don't just wanna walk
out on them but I've always kept my
career first before anything so that's
why I'm like the longer I stay the worse
it is for me so it's time to go let me
get you up though I lazy wet
I have nothing but time to think nothing
but time to look out the window I wonder
about what I'm going to do 15 20 years
now I have to win to go back to the
Olympics see you I don't win the Olympic
Trials
there is no Olympics there is no more
USA Boxing stipend well I have to move
back to Flint I do believe that when
another Olympic gold medal but just
because I believe it don't mean it's
going to happen ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the Olympic team trials for
women's boxing here in Rio
Memphis Tennessee
24 female boxers in the nation competing
for the chance to cover Rio de Janeiro
for the 2016 wins middleweight winners
bracket
Clarissa Shields in the red corner from
Flint Michigan against tika Hemingway in
the blue corner from Vania
I can't afford to have a bad fight we
have a close fight anymore they're gonna
be a lot harder on me now that I'm you
know top dog and he's either dominating
or don't she understands this time
around that it's much more than just
about winning goal that her image that
her personality play a much bigger role
people said that when you talk you seem
like a Willie are you seeing pretty
cocky I don't have to change myself
people to accept me
I don't care what nobody thinks
[Applause]
[Applause]
ha
[Applause]
Oh
you look up to our beautiful one-man
dictionaries had my face winter
just having me in the backing for to box
the way that I do that's what I think is
really beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think everybody thinks that 2012 was a
fluke like I got lucky or something
[Music]
yeah okay
they can't think that now
[Music]